welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz and this
is the show where every single monday
i'm going to be sitting down with
high-performing recruiters or successful
recruiting entrepreneurs to uncover how
they have remained at the top of their
game by discussing their daily habits
uncovering their mindset their approach
to leadership and much much more in this
week's episode i was joined by steph
bateman who is the founder of educate
staffing steph had a difficult journey
she became a young mom at 18 years old
so she had to juggle being a mum for the
first time whilst building her
recruitment career and later on her
recruitment business but despite those
challenges she's been on a fantastic
journey where she unlocked her inner
confidence she's grown as a leader and
she's now leading a recruitment company
that's doing multi-million pounds in
turnover you're gonna really enjoy this
episode hit like subscribe so you know
every time we release a new episode on
monday enjoy steph welcome to the
podcast thank you thanks for uh the
first guest that's come a bit late
so i'm gonna learn from that one i'm
gonna put a bit of an emphasis on
turning up
on time sorry about that
but where we always like to start is
is the million pound question in
recruitment and i'm sure it's a question
that you've asked yourself a lot since
growing your own recruitment company so
yeah i want to hear your take on it so
in your view what characteristics and
traits do you really believe make up a
highly successful recruitment consultant
in in today's market
um it is a million dollar question um
and i ask myself it every time i
interview people um i think that one of
the characteristics that you can't
really get away from is people need to
want
to be successful and they need to want
to do well the reason why i don't think
you can say is because of just money
because there is different reasons and
but i don't know anyone that has done
well that hasn't really really wanted to
um you know they've been a bit
half-hearted about it so i'd say that
for number one and i think number two
you have to be personable
if you can't build relationships
it's it's not gonna go that well for you
yeah and i think i have interviewed
people and i have hired people that you
wouldn't immediately think are
personable
but over time like you know you go out
on socials with them and you realize
actually they are and if they don't have
that trait then
and it's something that's quite hard to
learn you can build on it but yeah i'd
say those two things
do you so um i had pat sit down before
you and said a similar thing around
drive yeah so just always curious i
guess like firstly where where's that
where's that come for yourself but have
you always had it was it your
circumstances growing up that really go
gave you sort of drive i don't know
anything what what do you think really
gave you that um i think that i found
one of interview people that my reason
and my drive was probably quite unique
to me okay and so i haven't been able to
relate to that many people with it but
mine was that i guess my story without
going into too much death was that like
i needed to make money i had i had to
pay for a child yeah i had to put a roof
over my head
and i had no other choice i was working
two jobs and it was like that was my
drive it was like i just need to
actually like meet my basic needs yeah
yeah yeah um so that that was my initial
drive but as you go on and you earn
money it was like i had this like
addiction to success in my eyes and so
then that drove my continuous um i guess
just my ambition yeah
curious
how
how comfortable have you found it
yourself personally and then also
with your friends female friends
talking about money
um
i definitely i'm not
as open now as i would have been
probably when i first started out in
recruitment because i felt like
we were all in similar situations in in
essence and we were all kind of like
struggling for money a little bit
whereas i think now
i'm probably in a slightly different
place
to them so i wouldn't talk about it that
much come across in like an arrogant way
yeah yeah yeah i'd be conscious of that
so i don't i don't speak that openly i
was just curious because i was speaking
to my um girlfriend about this and like
i don't know i do in terms of like the
uk i don't know there's definitely
sometimes shame attached talking about
money and like yeah i've just definitely
had to really push my girlfriend
sometimes to talk about
like to be proud of like that she's got
a pay rise and she's i don't know if you
found that that's what i was just
curious i'm massively doing i think that
for me money's been quite
a key thing within my life because i've
it's been difficult and so it's been
something which i've
always been like i've always talked
about it i've like always create budget
spreadsheets like i'm quite particular
about it and so
i'm very like with my partner
it was something that he
wouldn't really talk about and i had to
make those conversations happen because
i'm like well if we're in a relationship
then these things need to be out in the
open yeah and so i think that
i do find that society generally they
will steer clear of having those kinds
of conversations and it's like if you're
if you're doing quite well financially
and people around you aren't
you do feel a little bit like okay this
is this could be an awkward conversation
so you probably avoid it it's
interesting
so
i want to really talk a lot about your
own business journey yeah but let's just
sort of touch on it so from what what i
took in in preparing for this it looked
like you worked for like two quite big
brands
yeah right so worked at randstad and
then what was the other company um
trade wins
yeah so
so i guess when you said that like you
literally needed to be in an environment
where the earning potential was there
yeah was that going into recruitment or
was that what recruitment really gave
you them when you first landed and like
how did you how did you find yourself in
recruitment uh quite an interesting
story actually so i i my sister was a
net so she's five years older she has a
recruitment company now
and but she was doing it and she earned
quite good money and i originally was
trying to get into management
consultancy because i was like i don't
want to do sales because i worked i
think we'll touch like i worked for a
company called ibi for angels which was
just sales yeah and so i was like no i
don't want to do that
and then she was doing really well and i
thought right i need to make money
quickly so and i'm not getting into
management consultancy because my maths
is was quite poor and i tried to get
into a graduate scheme didn't make it
and so
i was like right recruitment's going to
be i'm just going to give it a go i went
for four interviews for a rec to rack
didn't get any of them really yeah what
was the feedback um
couldn't present well wow shy
shy
definitely wouldn't see it really yeah
yeah 100 i used to get really like
flustered talking couldn't really um
which is why i touched on earlier about
developing person like being personable
because i definitely wasn't someone
initially that was just like a trainer
and that was obvious then i was like
well you know i've i've got to do
something now because i'd actually left
my job i for you for angels so i had a
gap she did like i had no money yeah so
i did the same thing and then when you
start speaking to recruiters you learn
that's not that doesn't look very good
does it no no no no no no no no it
doesn't look good like you've left one
job and you've never been about another
yeah
yeah yeah i always ask i drew people on
that
um but yeah no i i did it um
and and so then when i was looking at
other jobs i was like well i'm going to
do this myself i'm like having no
success with these recruiters so i've
applied myself to a job at branstad
which at the time the salary that they
were advertising was 24k really which
started that like like that and that was
quite a few years ago
many years ago and that was so high so
like and i remember getting my first pay
pack and they'd underpaid me really and
i was like everything was about money
yeah that's why i said to them i was
like what's going on yeah like you've
underpaid me they're like well we never
said you're being paid like that that
salary that's that's too high for your
level and i was like this is the advert
this is what i came in for and then they
they changed it really
yes i was really really lucky but um it
was i interviewed there and it was for
i.t or education
i got second for both not again i'm not
really too sure how um and then i was
like i'm not going to do both i'm going
to ch so i went with the one that i
really liked the manager
and so
which was education yeah and that was
how it happens
so let because i want to make sure we
touch on this because i think a lot a
lot of people can learn from it or i
think a lot of people
may see themselves with how you describe
yourself when you're going to these
interviews so i guess the best way to
sum that up would maybe be inner
confidence or those like how did you i
know we're just speaking before we
started but like talk to us a bit about
how you went about unlocking that i
guess because yeah whenever i've met you
and spoke to you i'll never sort of
attack you with things like shy and you
get what i mean
how do you go about unlocking that for
people that may want to grow their
confidence which a lot of people do yeah
yeah yeah so i used to and i still do
now i love learning new things i love
like trying to challenge myself
and so i could quite clearly see from
having not got to a second stage in the
first four interviews that that was one
of my problems
and so i was like i didn't really know
how to make it better so i just
literally like went on google yahoo
maybe it was back then
um and looked into how to build
relationships and so i just listened to
yeah
and so i literally just listened to like
youtube videos i listened to like
everything i possibly could i read books
i actually can't remember there wasn't
really any books i'd say would stand out
but just within that time period and i
spoke with my sister because she also
did it as well and i just try to
adjust the way that what i was doing and
just try and put things in place like
breathing and like being able to prep
for questions a bit more and and really
just enjoying it instead of thinking
about oh what they thinking or what's
happening um and i think that like even
the interviewer that i had for randstad
i remember one of them said oh no we
can't hire her because she's just she's
going to be too difficult to manage
really so i must have made quite a
u-turn from like the first four
interviews to that for them to then say
that but i think yeah just just a little
bit of like really self
self-development self-development and
trying to teach myself something new
around how i was like portraying myself
because it was very different from from
ibf angels
would that be your advice then for
people listening i'm sure you're trying
to help people with this in your own
business yeah i would say that they
should just really try and like even
just practice stuff in the mirror really
like to to become more comfortable with
having a conversation with someone that
you're not used to but but being able to
be like ask questions that you okay i'm
not prepared for this
and just become comfortable with it
speaking it is it's such a
useful skill isn't it yeah like it can
help you in all areas of your life yeah
i think if any job that you're going for
if you're
if any industry that growing
that you're going for if you're not
coming across as someone that's you know
a little bit confident or a little bit
personable then it's going to go against
you even if maybe you've made some
incorrect answers that they perhaps
weren't looking for then i think that is
that that will kind of get you half the
way yeah
so you're touching that early then so
chrome throng you've got a little girl
right
yeah how so how old was you when you had
your little girl then uh 18. wow
so then
so like pretty much so you've obviously
been
um raising how you pretty much your
whole entire career basically yeah so i
remember she was
so i think i was 21 when i went into
recruitment i just finished my degree
um because the other job that i used to
do was was nights and
she said yeah i think she must have been
too
yeah i did not because because i had her
and i still had to have an income and i
was at uni so i was like so i did three
generally free nights it was a bit
flexible so you could do more if you
wanted to earn more money because it was
commission only right yeah and then had
her when yes so i think she was two when
i went into it yeah wow so she's been in
every office i've worked hard
really yeah she's come to visit she's
like got on the phone that's amazing
because i know when i called you i've
had um i haven't had loads of people but
i've had a handful of people on
the podcast that have had to raise a
family i think i'd like to think that
the sort of needles change on it where
steph being a young mum in recruitment
five ten years ago would be entirely
different to
how it would be now i'd like to think so
anyway in terms of
companies being more remote or being
more open to being flexible because yeah
i've had a lot of people on here where
basically they've had a child or they
started to raise a family and then they
sort of went their careers in
recruitment they've had some sort of
like ultimatum where it's like ah like
am i going to be able to carry on with
my career when i come back and it's for
a lot of people shared that it was just
they made it really difficult for them
yeah they lost their contract book like
i don't know
those things so i guess it'd be great if
you could just talk to us a bit about
how you've gone about and i'm sure
there's been plenty of good days and bad
days yeah but how have you gone about
juggling being steph the mum yeah when
you walk through the door at home to
being someone that's driven money hungry
and and have to have to perform at work
as well with clear
huge responsibilities on your shoulders
yeah i think
i think one of the things is that
like
in my eyes i didn't give myself a choice
okay it was that i was so determined to
build a career that was successful
and i think that a lot of people when i
was was growing up
and found out that i was pregnant and
stuff and i was having a liar at quite a
young age
that didn't believe in what i was going
to be able to achieve and were like yeah
you're probably just going to you know
go on to benefit yeah and not get a job
or not finish uni
and i think because of that i was really
just
committed to
or i guess a little bit proving them
wrong yeah it could be quite stubborn um
and i think secondly like when you're
going through that you just
her needs a number one so making sure
that you've got your organized that you
have a routine like i probably don't
know how to sit still now because
it was it's you're constant you're
constantly you're going you're going
going and so i'm not good like people
will say to me now like i just you you
don't want to chill out but but i do but
i have probably different things that i
do to chill out now because she's 13 now
so it's like she's she's like
self-sufficient yeah
but i think when she was a baby and it
was like doing recruitment i think it
was it it was just and i still i still
had a social life i still did other
stuff it wasn't like that was the only
thing i did like live and breathe
recruitment and have her i think it was
just
being able to make sure that like i was
organized like everything was sorted and
there were days when that didn't go to
plan and that you would have to adapt
and you'd have to work stuff out but
there was it was always okay you know no
one was ever it was not like i was ever
in a situation where really i probably
couldn't go to work or there wasn't
flexibilities at work definitely because
i had to start at seven so that was hard
um
and
and i broke up with my partner so that
made it difficult but
there's always a solution
like that was there was never a time
where
i was like i'm giving up because that's
what it really is like yes it's hard it
is hard yeah you've you've decided to
have a child so that is your
responsibility so now it's your
responsibility to to make that happen
and still build your career and if
people don't
in my opinion
there's never really a strong enough
reason
besides the fact that you decided that
you're not going to do it
well good on you i shouldn't like you
just like you just said you looked for
you had a solutions mindset and a
positive mindset rather than yeah but
that must have been difficult yeah like
100 it's it there was many times where
i i would think to myself god i've got
it harder than everyone else
um not not that i wanted to give up but
like oh god my life's hard i would never
tell anyone that but like in my head i'd
say that to myself but then i'm like i'm
achieve it i'm not i used to say to
myself i'm not going to compare myself
to others around me and even in my job
in recruitment i was like i'm i want to
be better than everybody around me i
want to be able to
be the be that person that to myself is
incomparable to anyone
and so like that was the thing for me it
was like being a mom and doing and doing
that was like well yeah i'm doing it and
yeah okay it's quite hard but i'm
choosing to do that for myself no one's
making me do it i love that let's go
into educated staffing then so she
worked at those two brands so
what was the first year like uh because
like like what did the business look
like in year one because that's
typically the hardest was it just you
just me smashing that for the whole
first year was this year um no i did
employ somebody um
i think it was
at the sixth month i employed someone
didn't work out but you know all of
these things learning curves
and for the first six months i literally
did everything from
invoices compliance
marketing if you could call if there was
any marketing happening then it was
minimal um
yeah everything and so for the first we
broke even by the sixth month
i think it was six months was it many
attempts temp recruitment that he did at
that time
so a lot of our stuff it is temp but
you'll usually place somebody into a job
and then they'll stay there if if
they're good for like the academic year
sometimes longer okay so so yes we it's
contracts but it will be like
yeah yeah
and there's day to today but then the
day-to-day is a lot of it to be fair to
begin with i did used to say to clients
like don't come to me for day-to-day
what do you mean by that sorry so like i
call you in the morning then you're like
yeah i've got a supply teacher that can
come in today yeah sometimes that could
work like that pretty much that so we
would stipulate it within the business
that what i did for myself that anything
below five weeks right would be it would
be a day-to-day because sometimes we'll
get clients that will call in so i need
somebody next week yeah yeah and i need
them for two weeks and then actually
sometimes it goes into a long term or
you get the calls in the morning like at
the moment that are crazy
um i think because of covid that they
want somebody on the day
wow and that's why we have what just
yeah oh that's mad yeah so it's very
very fast-paced and intense in that
sense
okay and then and then how much perm did
you do then just because it should be
good for people to understand um in that
first six months none okay not not in
the first six months because i know some
people build their business or
permanently we i didn't do that okay pem
wasn't an area that i was used to or had
any kind of drive to try and make that
biggest i wasn't used to it but then as
the business has gone on i'd say
probably now
perm makes up about
10
of the business
possibly even 20 because we've had we
have found we've had quite a bit more
but that might just be where the
business has grown
so how have you so like i haven't had
many people on
the podcast that recruit in your sector
so so it'd be really just good to just
break down a few things so
firstly like how have you like from my
outside looking in and i feel like
in those types of sectors if it's
education and sometimes other public
sectors yeah you have a lot of like the
big like ramstad and these things are
like really well established got loads
of people smashing the phone from 7am
until whatever time like how did you
compete like just step in the office on
your own like how did you compete hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast partners vincerie
and sauce breaker because you listened
to this podcast you were able to get
your hands on exclusive savings on both
of these award-winning products if
you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with sourcebreaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out sourcebreaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products well you know i i think honor
so so for me branstad actually they had
like a pop-up branch for education so
they weren't that to me they weren't a
big competitor
but trade wins yeah
they're an amazing company they do
things very well i learned so much there
so what i took from that experience was
like okay
i've got a really big competitor here
that i know inside out because i've
worked there for how long
um what can i change about what they do
that's going to make my business
different and have a usp and better and
it for me it was service server it was
service and it was
because the company was quite big and
there was lots of other companies out
there that were big that one of the
things that was missing was providing
somebody that elite level of service and
so you know our referrals are like we
get so many referrals because every part
of what we do
we will ensure it's like i guess a good
analogy would be
going on like a
maybe a first-class flight or like an
emirates flight against an easyjet yeah
yeah and it was like we wanted to
provide that experience that through
every step of the way that the candidate
was like oh wow and they just want to
work through us sure
because we all know it's like a
candidate a candidate-led market in most
recruitment sectors
and so and that was one of the things
that when i first started in recruitment
i never realized i i i don't know if it
was necessarily a candidate-led market
but now
i think that
over time it's definitely so much that
that if you don't provide that level of
experience
then what
what are you offering that they haven't
already got why would they come to us
yeah and i guess particularly in your
working environment like
like i had um pat here before and he
recruits in tekken he was comparing that
like
you have people out there who
transactional recruitment and one two
three deals but now he's
probably into like um selling solutions
and solving business problems and having
those conversations and i feel like
in your environment i've just seen this
through companies or people i've met in
like the healthcare environment as well
like it can be even more transactional
like if i'm calling the staff recruiter
at seven saying hey have you got me a
job or whatever i don't know like it
could be so easy as well in your
environment i guess
to just give like a really poor level of
service and just view these people as
just five weeks
to get what i mean i feel like yeah your
environment could just um facilitate
that transaction even more yeah i think
i think it does and i think that's the
trap that a lot of recruiters fall into
especially as i'm training trainees
i have to really really instill the
service because it is so fast-paced
that
they feel like that's a lesser important
part of what they're doing because it's
like we just need to get someone in but
it's that's not what we're trying to
build as a brand and i know that there's
a lot of companies that that's what they
do and it works and it's successful
but that's the one reason that
i was successful as a recruiter was that
if somebody's relying on you for a
service that that service is the
communication's amazing it's regular
it's more frequent than what they're
used to and that's the reason why we
have people that come back
um but it isn't something that i think
is obvious within such a transactional
market and so it's just making sure that
all those little bits aren't missed and
so we have a lot more things done around
the service that i feel like are just
little touches
that help there's an example
so one of the things we do um i'm not
sure if this is the best one that i can
but it comes to mind is um it's like
this little pink envelope so it's our
lovely pink brand color yeah which is
not my favorite color but anyway we send
that to every candidate that starts
working for us okay and and inside it is
chocolates yeah and a lorty scheme thing
and also a um
a lot a lot i say a little laundry skin
thing so they go on to a loyalty scheme
okay and so everyone that works for us
earns a loyalty point for every day that
they work okay and then they can claim
back the points for rewards oh that's
quite there so it's a little bit
different yeah and we try and like make
sure that where it's like better than
tesco's club
um yeah that's awesome like little
touches like that yeah little touches
like that and i think that like
sometimes it just means a lot to people
sometimes people just like whatever but
you know those little things that people
realize yourself memorable aren't you
yeah i think sorry and just showing that
you care um
correct me if i'm wrong but like you're
in in march you educate stuff from me
going for six years
yeah
so a lot of companies that make it
that far yeah people say this to me and
i don't know any stats around it but
yeah that's what i keep hearing what
what do you think
that like again if we're sitting here
just
thinking of the last six years like what
do you think has enabled you to
continue going in the right direction
and and yeah i'm obviously being where
you are as a business today like i don't
know what do you think of the things
that you really stay true to the the key
parts of that that you've
really made sure that yeah are
non-negotiable as if it's the service
and these things but i don't know last
six years what what was it that you made
sure you did i think develop a process
because you can't really scale if you
don't have processes in place you have
to have good people around you
i think that's that's non-negotiable and
i think
i was very much to begin with and i feel
like if i could re do the last six years
i'd realize that like i'm i don't know
everything and what did you think you
did i think i think i i was very like
i'm right okay and it's it's not about
being right or wrong it's about well
what can you learn and who can you
have relationships around you that are
gonna help you know grow stuff
so i think taking on good advice and
actually implementing that because i've
got an amazing business partner and he
always said to me in the first couple of
years he's like if you just listen to me
[Laughter]
what was it like preventing you from
listening do you think just
i think because he had a business in
the medical sector yeah and i
might my business be in education i was
like yeah but you know that doesn't
apply for education right right so
possibly that um
and but yeah that's probably it because
he did really really well and so there
shouldn't have really been a reason
where i was like well he doesn't know
best yeah yeah so yeah i'd probably say
that but i think that being able to just
ensure that
yes there's going to be hard times like
god those couple first couple of years i
cried a lot like yeah that was my way of
dealing with it emotionally was like i'd
go and have go in a room and i'd have a
cry
and i think that's one of the things
that probably i don't necessarily see
that many people that own businesses
show their weaknesses and senses and
it's like it is hard but at the same
time what what amazing things to achieve
through things that are just easy so how
did how did you deal with the overwhelm
then because i think a lot of people can
be feeling this right now yeah that
speaks a lot of recruiters who have got
the most jobs that they ever have or
these things like how how have you got
better at dealing with the overwhelm
because now it's not just
steph providing for your family steph is
also
has created a business where you're
supporting how many employees you got
they're relying on you to to pay them
and those things like how
have you got better at dealing with the
overwhelm yeah or do you still go and
cry
in the meeting room
i actually
don't but
and you would think because now i've got
more people it'd be harder
which in ways it is but it's mindset
okay i think that thankfully now like
you know maybe positive negative like
the world talks a lot more about mindset
and how how you deal with things
but i think if you have
certain ways of being able to deal with
the way that you you generally will
treat your emotions in your head or
feelings
that is it your typical way and you
don't really change it then you're
probably not going to progress
that much and things will still be hard
whereas now
i still definitely have moments where
i'm like okay that's stressful but i
feel like i have ways of being able to
deal with it i like i openly say i have
therapy once a week okay and that has
been hugely beneficial for me i haven't
had therapy like when did that start
it's probably been so i did the landmark
which i know that you know i've
mentioned to you that was like the
beginning of like my i think my mindset
journey
and then i i loved it i like i got
people to work i was like landmark was
just amazing for me but then
i all i didn't carry like i've done
probably about over two years maybe
different courses how would you describe
landmark really quickly just for anyone
that hasn't
heard of it
i felt like it was a bit of a cult yeah
it's like a bit of a personal
development yeah
i think people can do so it depends on
like where you're at in your mind of it
so for me
it helped me deal with a lot of things
that i've dealt like in my past that i
probably hadn't ever addressed sure that
were like coming out with different
different problems yeah i was quite an
angry person really yeah
and so i think now i i just it's
different ways to deal with stuff and
different ways to view things so it was
really good for me but i do agree like
not everybody would necessarily get
amazing things from it i've got better
relationships contacts networking
um i would say it's
yeah i don't know how to summarize it
what um how would you how do you
describe
like your sort of personal benefits or
of of um having a therapist and
a therapist each week so that's that's
my chill by the way because you know i
was like oh don't chill out that's
that's like my chill 15 minutes i feel
like every week because i can just
literally
i i've probably i've realized from it
that i um i struggle to
everything's so fast-paced i don't stop
sure so whilst i'm doing something i'm
thinking about four other things at the
same time so i'm not solely focused on
one thing yeah so i think that it's
helped me be able to be in the moment
more and be able to actually for example
with staff be able to actually listen to
what they're saying and like really give
the best possible response to because
like you said earlier like they're
dealing with loads of stuff
and you are
they're like they they're kind of
relying on you and hoping that you're
going to give them the advice and
support which kind of isn't in your job
title but it is at the same time
um so i think
that part has been really helpful and i
think being able to realize that
failure's okay okay because i probably
don't accept very well that failure's um
allowed in my in my brain when it's like
it's okay it doesn't need to be like
failure it's the worst thing ever
and that's going to be a beneficial
thing and i think just being able to
just
cope with like everything in a
you know you don't have to have to get
worked up about situations
that you know there's five things
happening you know there's there's ten
people calling your phone and you know
this phone's ringing someone's talking
to you because that that was probably a
hard thing for me to to manage was the
fact the business is growing and
everybody wants to speak steph yeah yeah
and
which is fine you know i've created that
but then how do you create it so that
people know right i'm available then
this is when you can speak to me this is
our time together outside of that i'm
doing this yeah and you've got to be
responsible for yourself
yeah 100 and you're timing and like i
used to make myself available for
everyone at every every minute and that
was something just went a bit too far
that way yeah yeah yeah yeah because i
thought i could just do everything
well um so really quickly on this
how did you go about finding a therapist
because i've spoken to a couple of
people about this and i think that can
be quite overwhelming like where do we
even where do i go where do i start like
how was that for you really quickly i
mean
did you get recommended i cheated a
little bit on this because i have a pa
so she actually found her
um
but do you have any idea how she like
found someone or i think she just went
online really she just literally went
online and googled like therapists
and i had one and it didn't work out and
so i have a different one now who who it
just works me because she's just like
kind of tells me a bit more like how it
is and i'm it's just a bit more plain
and simple whereas i don't really like
like pussyfooting around just like get
to the point yeah okay um
and so that that worked quite well for
me but i think so we actually have an
internal therapist for the business
really yeah because i found that with
kovid like people's mental health was a
real
worry for for like not just one employee
but for quite a few and how they were
managing with like not going out and
being at home and yeah all the things
that people have dealt with throughout
craven um and that particular person
that i've actually got was a really
unique relationship so she was one of my
clients she was a head teacher okay um
and she started working for me as a
supply teacher and then she was like
steph i'm going to stop working for you
supply teacher i was like oh my god why
i'm training to be a therapist
and so she now does that um and we
so whoever wants it
can ask for it and then it's completely
private that we'll just pay towards it
so we're paying the majority of it and
then the the person who's having it
after the first three sessions i'll just
carry on and you know for some people
it's been really really helpful for
other people like yeah it wasn't really
for me which which is fine but we've
it's just an additional way to say look
we're here to help yeah yeah and support
you through whatever whereas like you
know when i first started the business
i'd have been like we're not doing that
for people like we're here to make money
and it's a business but it's so much
more than that um
what other things like that have you
invested in maybe that you think has
impacted culture or impacted
because basically what what that's going
to do is it's likely going to impact
performance isn't it yeah people being
happier and well which means they're
going to perform better likely anything
else that you ended up have ended up
investing in that's had quite a positive
impact do you think i would say
i mean socials are important it's an
obvious one but i do think socials can
be overlooked especially frack covert
and it's such a a good way to be able to
just get people out of work mode and be
able to like actually build better
relationships relationships with them
because
you know even no matter how big your
business is it we're in a relationship
industry so if you've got good
relationships with your staff that's
going to be crucial um for them wanting
to stay like i don't think i can say
i've ever lost anyone in the business
that i was left
off their own back and gone to a
competitor really no unfortunately i've
always had a little bit of a sacking
mentality for the first few years so i
did attack a few people
but then i realized that that's actually
um not everyone's going to be amazing
really quick so i've adjusted um but
yeah i think that well you held them to
your standards
yeah really yeah everyone needed to be
like me and if they weren't it was a
problem and it's that's just not the way
that the world is yeah so yeah i've
realized that it took me a little while
but um i'd say also things like
just having this is again sounds like a
bit of an obvious one but taking the
time to make sure that like checking in
with everyone
so like we do holidays away every year
and stuff like that and we do things
like you know add-ons like private
healthcare and we're looking at jim like
supporting with gym membership and stuff
but i think actually just just like
having a discussion you know people need
time and they need you need to be able
to find out like what's going on with
them so it's just having that balance
between
making sure you make that time but not
too much time that it's becoming
detrimental love it obviously you've
been on such a journey of your sort of
leadership it seems like yeah massively
yeah i think like i've only got 15 staff
so
and i feel like after six years
you know don't get me wrong it's not all
about how many staff you have it's
ultimately you you're not you're not
happy with where you're at you think you
should be further along yeah not that
it's just on 15 heads but yeah because
what has the revenue gone in the right
direction yeah so surprisingly the last
few years covid
was like a big concern yes we were gonna
do better last year than we already did
but we still had the better ever
since you started what the revenue was
we did last what year are we in yeah
five and i'm finishing it yeah five we
finished on
after everything
i think it was two
we done oh 2.8 turnover
and i think after everything we did half
a million
of my head and i should know because
we're actually just filing our accounts
and then
this year we on
track to do
i think three and a half turnover yeah
so our revenue should be
750 i think it is after the next income
or the
gp so i call it so gp
so that we've got turnover the night so
everyone calls it different things so
the gp wise will do
a million this year yeah and then and
then after you've paid everything after
you've paid everything yeah yeah no that
doesn't sound right no no that's not
right it doesn't matter anyway that's
going in the right direction
yeah it's gone so so so much better i
think i didn't really
i just thought that we'd be here a
little bit quicker
and i think that all of the little
things i've learned that now i feel like
we're going to excel even quicker yeah
and like all of those little i know it's
once you get bigger it's harder to add
on 50 50 each year but i do feel like it
should get quite a bit better quicker
now because we've got more better people
in a team better talent better processes
learned from the lessons that we've
learned from already so
it's quite exciting i love it so what as
you come to the end then like what's
where do you want the business to be
this time next year or like what's
what's the what's the next thing for you
where do you want to be
i'm sure you have big goals big
ambitions so i think like this so our
financial year now is different so so i
often financial year ends in august okay
so for this year now that we're in
september to august
like i
am really really committed to making
sure that we hit our revenue target yeah
so for me yes we've got gross profit and
that's important but we're over that
already for this year so that's looking
really good but then we're spending too
much money okay so it's like making sure
that everything's aligned in that sense
so like yes i want to achieve that but
at the same time over the next like in
the next year
i want to push manchester um
because that didn't work out i want to
develop the business so that are
and really relevant i think for this is
making sure that our trainees are in
three months in and they're profitable
yeah yeah and so far it's like we've
done it with a few but not with
everybody
so it's just really making sure that
process is solidified and then it's like
you've got such a good
system and process around everything
that it's like a little um
formula
so i just want to make sure like that's
solid and that we can keep growing and
obviously there's going to be problems
it's not going to be like yeah i've got
the formula that's it
um but yeah
manchester and that formula of getting
trainees three months in and
and then flying because ultimately
you've got people that were probably not
on great salaries that are able to earn
money really quickly really well and i
love that that's why i have the
businesses is that yes i want to be
successful but i love seeing people be
successful and be able to like earn
money they've never earned before i love
that
well look steph it's been a pleasure
thank you thank you so much
honestly i think you'll inspire a lot of
people thank you
i think it's great the journey that
you've been on so thank you thank you
very much for having me
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you got value from the
conversation and there was a number of
key takeaways so please don't forget to
like share and please do share your key
takeaways in the comments below if you
did have some and uh thanks for
supporting the show